Thank you so much.
Sure. Dave. Uh, I'm not the man
of the hour though. These two are,
we have, uh, the founder
of ripple, Chris Larson,
and we have it's current CTO,
Stefan Thomas. Uh, we're very,
very excited to have them.
This is going to be an awesome talk.
A little kind of brief intro. Chris
got his MBA from Stanford. He started,
he alone, which is a kind
of a mortgage lender, a,
it was actually the first platform to
freely give out fico credit scores to its
users. Uh, he started prosper,
which is actually the first p to p peer
to peer lending marketplace in the u s
uh, and famously he cofounded ripple
labs, which is a subject of today's talk.
They're really excited to have Chris
here. Stefan Thomas is a Cto, uh,
of ripple labs. Uh, he was the CTO of, uh,
numerous tech companies like e
load and tech bear. He founded, uh,
we use coins which created this
kind of bit coin primer video,
which amassed 8 million views and was a
primer for a lot of people to just learn
about kind of the basics of bitcoin.
And that kind of blew up on the web.
So I'd check that out. Um, and
he's a board of directors. Uh,
he's on the board of directors,
sorry,
at the js foundation and
he's a current CTO of ripple.
Ripple is, uh, describes itself as
the only enterprise solution, um,
uh, for blockchain. Uh, it allows
institutions to send money globally,
uh, and a fast, frictionless and
cheaper way. Uh, and it's broad.
It's kind of broader. Uh, eventual aim
is to create an, an Internet of value,
which I'm really excited to talk
to both of these guys about.
A so without further ado, please, uh,
give, give a hand for Chris and Stefan
[inaudible].
Awesome guys. Um, so, uh,
can you guys just give us kind of a
brief bio, uh, in, in your own words, uh,
your career and how you came to found
ripple labs and then get involved.
Great. A habit to you at, first of all,
thanks for having us and thanks
for not making a Bart Simpson joke.
I appreciate that. So, uh,
yeah, as you mentioned,
we've been in Fintech for
about 20 years now, um,
with kind of two startups previously.
He loaner prosper kind of
the common thread there.
Those were focused on the consumer ripple.
Obviously it's focused on enterprise
and there's some learnings that I,
that I had from that I'll share later.
But the idea there was using the
internet to democratize finance. Um,
I think we did a lot of good there.
Um,
but we were always limited by just a
fundamental lack of infrastructure in
Fintech. So kind of in my view, Fintech,
it really hasn't even started. Um,
it has sort of been a stepchild
of the internet boom, um,
because fintech really has to involve
both data and money and so far you've only
had the ability to move data.
So there really both a lot of excitement,
a lot of frustration that we couldn't
go further at the same time. Um,
it was always keeping an eye on what
was going on with virtual currencies.
And you know, Bitcoin, obviously
it was a real breakthrough,
but there've been a lot of
attempts over the years.
And so we were watching things
like, uh, Lyndon dollars,
which was currency and you know, uh,
that kind of existed in the early days.
Second life.
Phil Rossdale kind of an amazing guy.
He's still the coolest guy in
Crypto, right? Um, you know,
things like Vermont dollars,
kind of this idea of local
currencies in a very small community.
Super interesting. Um, obviously
beans and floors, which were too big,
well funded projects during the
first.com boom. That sort of, you know,
failed spectacularly,
but it just seemed like it was a matter,
a matter of time before you'd have
a global, a digital asset with no,
you know, kind of government
backing and no counterparty. Um,
as far as ripple itself, that route is
actually go back to about Oh four. Um,
there was, uh, something called the
ripple project created by a Ryan Fugger,
a Canadian,
a gentleman,
and he was just really a neat guy and
he tried really to kind of give birth to
this idea of a peer to
peer. Um, platform for,
uh, people exchanging their own credit
and essentially their own currency.
Every person would have their own
currency. Super interesting concept. Um,
that was a big part of what influenced
us kind of fast forward to 2011 and there
was these three geniuses that
got together. Um, Arthur Breteau,
Jed McCaleb and David Schwartz.
Um,
and this is of course after bitcoin
was created a couple of years earlier.
They were fascinated by what bitcoin did,
but they were frustrated by the enormous
waste of energy that is sort of at the
heart of mining. That's a core
part of, of, uh, of bitcoin.
So they set out to build a more efficient
consensus algorithm and they came up
with something really beautiful.
Um,
they also were inspired by what Ryan
figurehead head down at the ripple project
and kind of also brought in that idea of
kind of pathfinding algorithms so that
anything of value can be exchanged
along with that digital asset to really,
I think that was kind of the, the, the,
the birth point of this Internet of value,
the intellectual protocol, which we'll
show in a little bit. Um, actually has,
it's almost like an overlay protocol over
blockchains but then also traditional
financial systems and that allows you
to innovate in different parts of the
network independently instead of having
the sort of central governance model
where everyone has to agree to any,
any rule changes that are happening.
I think this is like a critical point.
I think we came to the realization that
a blockchain was not going to be the
solution to the biggest problem we think
the world has right now in this whole
Fintech area, which is there is no
Internet of value. Um, and why block,
you know,
and a lot of people talking
about bitcoin's going to be
a new protocol for money.
Well, just it's really a
database, right? So it,
a single database or a single network
cannot be the network of networks.
And so that was kind of the big flaw and
that's what led to, I think, you know,
Stefan having this kind of Aha moment
of need for something like Ilp,
which was a dangerous moment for,
it was scary at first.
It was like we were trying, we were out
there promoting this acid, like Xrp,
like telling everyone, hey, you should
put all your balances on this ledger.
You should do all your transactions
through this one system. Um,
and we knew the friction from that.
But then again,
like stepping back from that
and suddenly saying like, oh,
they're going to be many systems was
very scary. And so we actually, uh,
waited almost a year to publish the
white paper until we had, um, you know,
in our minds of result of strategy around
what's extra p his role in this new
world and how do we make sure that our
technologies are still needed and it's
still necessary and can,
can benefit this new world.
Like how do we re architect everything
to serve this new world? Um,
so I think we're still in the process
of like rolling out all of the different
pieces. Um, but it was that sort of
one year period from, I would say, um,
you know,
mid 2014 when we first had
that realization to October,
2015 when the white paper
for intellectual came out,
where we tried to kind of
put all the pieces in place
for it because we have rip,
it always was different from big
going in that you could put
anything of value in it, right?
So this idea of kind of,
we'd call it IOUs or balances,
but really being value agnostic
and that then being the engine for,
for the exchange of that thing of value.
Um,
but having the combination of IOP
with Xrp, we think that's the,
that's kind of the,
the killer formula.
No, you can have any type of
failure like any currency,
but also any type of ledger. So like
anything from a centralized ledger to
chain, et cetera. And if we look
at kind of stepping way back,
kind of the macro problem that we
think in the world has this lack of an
Internet of value. Um, you know,
you kind of argue that this gets to the
heart of the problem with globalization,
which is obviously under a
lot of stress today, right?
It's kind of not working for a
lot of people and we kind of,
we don't think of it as like, well,
globalization's bad. We think of it.
Globalization is actually incomplete.
Until you have an Internet of value,
you really can't have true globalization.
You sort of need these three core
interoperability technologies working
altogether. You need interoperability
of data, of goods and money, right?
So the world today, of course has
interoperability of data. You know,
it's completely transformed the
world over the last 20 years.
It has interoperability and goods through,
you know,
a simple thing called the shipping
container, which you know,
before that was in vantage shipping stuff
was incredibly inefficient and labor
intensive stuff would arrive at one point
I had to be ripped apart and reshipped
and with a shipping container, you
know, your shipped to train the truck,
any port in the world, you have
interoperability goods since the 1950s.
That's Sorta what an Internet of value is.
It's like the shipping
container for value. And again,
that can't be a blockchain.
And blockchain is like a single
shipping company that will, you know,
you'll max out that shipping company and
you'll have a dependency on that one.
Shipping Company, shipping container, you
can create endless shipping containers.
It has no effect on any other
shipping containers that deployed.
That's sort of what Ilp is almost
the ultimate decentralization.
So that's kind of what we're,
how we're thinking about it
or the technique people in the
audience as a stateless protocol.
So you can literally just run it over
different systems so it doesn't keep any
balances,
et cetera.
And then we think we're really good
things happen when the world finally has a
full kind of globalization platform.
Um,
but this has to happen. And, and again,
what w what does this meeting now that
we don't have it right now? It means, uh,
you know, we all know, send him 50 bucks
to Europe is kind of impossible, right?
Yeah. Um, we know,
I think the example of the air bnb host
in Tanzania who should be making 29
bucks to on a rental. And by the end
of the day is nine bucks is showing up.
This is an actual example,
right? Um, so that's a,
that's a problem with relatively big
amounts of value. Think about, uh,
the 2 billion people in
the developing world. They,
the gates foundation would say they
need to be able to send 50 cents, uh,
to be real participants in the global
economy. Take that even further.
If you think about all the connected
devices and applications that probably
should be empowered to sand value,
that might need to be, you know,
a thousandth of a penny a,
that's just not possible until you
had this internet or value in place.
So the world is being held back by
this and we think that's the true
breakthrough that this whole,
whatever you want to call this
industry really is all about.
There are some detractors of,
of ripple that say it's kind of the
centralized block chain or the enterprise
blockchain. Uh, you know,
a lot of bitcoin loyalists and bitcoin
in general might have come out of kind of
a,
an anarchist or a cipher punk kind
of movement early on as part of that.
Uh, um, and uh, and so that, that's
kind of the general criticism.
So I wanted to give you guys a chance
to respond to that and then I'll combine
the second question because Stefan,
as an awesome presentation he's going
to give the second question is we are
living in a crazy kind of environment
in terms of crypto currency.
Just speculation on, on the price
of, of, of Tokens and blockchains.
Uh, what do you guys think? We're
in 1999 right now. Is this the, the,
the uh, you know, kind of a.com bubble
that we're experiencing? Um, so yeah,
those two.
Yeah,
I'll take the first one. You
can. Sure. Um, so first of all,
the enterprise part I
take as a compliment.
I think that's precisely what we're
trying to do is we're trying to build the
first blockchain that can actually be
used for real, you know, real use cases.
You know, like when you think
of any distributed system,
we need to take a
distributed systems class.
The first thing your
professor will tell you,
it's like your distributed system is still
only going to be as good as the nodes
that runs on.
And so if you think of bitcoin miners,
they're only incentivized to basically
hash as efficiently as possible.
They're not incentivized to provide
physical security for the data centers.
They're not incentivized to make decisions
in the interest of the network. Um,
so the,
the,
they have a very pure incentive to just
hash as much as possible get paid, um,
rinse and repeat.
In the case of ripples,
since the validators are chosen by
the users. If a validater for example,
votes against a block size
increase or something like that,
if there were an issue in, in ripple, um,
then you would eventually find that
users would no longer add that validated
should that list. And so that validated
would slowly lose influence. Um,
and so it's not as much of a system
that's like tailored to users like bitcoin
is where, you know, anyone can just run a
node and it just auto configures itself,
um, connects to the network. You do have
to do that validators selection manually.
You have to think about, you
know, politically speaking, like,
which validators do you want to
empower with your note, et Cetera. Um,
so it is more targeted at like, you know,
actively being managed by companies,
things like that,
things of that nature.
But I think the reason that that makes a
lot of senses because when you actually
go out there and to the market, um, you
know, the, the evil people, you know,
you mentioned I'm an anarchist,
you know, so I, I really
want to, uh, empower people,
right? But the people that
you got to fight or not the,
like all the banks there,
there a few, you know, very, very
powerful players in the market that,
that sort of take a
little bit off the top.
And those are the people that you want
to bypass. And then everyone else,
like there's a lot of small banks and
regional banks and so on that we've talked
to that are really trying to
provide better user experience.
You're really trying to
provide lower fees, et cetera.
Those are the companies that we want to
work with and empower and it's not just
banks, it's payment providers, mobile
money providers, um, and so on.
So that's kind of where that
different approach comes from.
And on the centralization point,
I would kind of say that there are
a lot of different definitions of
centralization and you know,
we're sort of going down the list of
meeting more and more of them as we
progress.
Um,
one of the ones that we don't meet yet
is that we still run a majority of the
trusted validators. Um, but
that's something that we're,
this year going to start
rolling out in terms of, um,
we have already got a lot of
third party validators running,
so people are going to start
trusting in this year. Um,
and so this just one more step
to kind of go in that direction.
And I think if I compare it to where we
were with Bitcoin, like with Bitcoin,
we had some level of decentralization.
Again, meeting some of the definitions,
but not all. For instance,
there's no geographic diversity.
It's very concentrated in China right now.
Um,
but we didn't have a very good roadmap
in order to how to overcome that because
the, the system is really, um, you know,
it's just sort of the incessant
centers are set up in a, in a,
I would now say bad way.
Um,
whereas with ripple we have
the incentives are in order.
And so it's just a matter of like, you
know, validators having the riot, the,
you know,
amount of operational histories of people
who actually start trusting them and
us having enough confidence in the
software to actually, um, you know,
continuously let go of more and more of
the reigns here. So I think it's, uh, uh,
for ripple,
it's a clearer roadmap to get to a
very high level of decentralization.
So bottom line in decentralization
is there's kind of a bright line,
you know, if rebel did not exist with
the network, continue to function. Yes.
So that's kind of that, you know,
hard line of which side you're on.
And then I think it's
definitely point variety.
We can agree deviations from there.
And then
a second I think on what's going on in
the market today. So obviously, you know,
it really interesting, you know,
the time in, in, in the space,
clearly there is a lot of UB
speculative interest that's going on.
And I kind of break that into
kind of two parts. Um, one, uh,
is there's clearly a lot of, of almost
like crypto day trading going on.
It's almost like the days of the early
Internet with all the, the day trading.
And I think it'd be probably,
if you look back on most people that
were day trading back in 2000, um,
I bet it didn't work out that well for,
for people that were doing that.
People shouldn't do that. You
could lose all the, you know,
you can lose everything. Um,
it's, it's just not a good plan.
People should not be putting the
retirement money to work day trading
cryptocurrencies. And then I think there's
a lot of skepticism that you, you know,
you see out there, uh, Nathaniel popper,
for example, the New York Times, you know,
he writes, uh, uh, about
that, uh, skeptically and
he's right to be skeptical.
So we think, you know, that people
should be very careful with that.
But there's a second part of speculation
I think is being now increasingly
driven by institutions.
So institutions, funds,
we would call it the Wall Street
tidal wave is sorta coming, uh,
coming into play here.
And I think what's going on there is that
a very sophisticated people are saying,
investors are saying,
look,
there's some meaningful percentage of
this is in fact a second internet and this
internet or value can be as
transfer transformational.
That's a longer term sort of call
that that's going to happen. Um,
so I'd say that's more
constructive speculation.
And I think those institutions
and those kinds of professionals,
they've seen what's happened in
this last, uh, 20 years of the net.
The great promise, the overhype,
uh, the, the, you know,
the total bubble,
the crash,
and then kind of fast forward 20 years
where we are today. If you look back,
you'd probably say probably
the early promise was probably,
it was probably under hyped given the
impact that all of this has had on human
existence. So that's a more
constructive, uh, view.
I think they use cases for industries,
enterprise payment providers and
other things that is coming on board.
Um,
so I suspect that sort of ratio of sort
of hopefully the longterm specularity of
injury, you know,
activity and the use case,
it starts to look more like what you see
in normal markets because this thing's
gonna actually work pretty
constructively together.
When was the last point in that I think
interesting is in the first internet
that kind of started with institutions,
vcs and then Wall Street and then kind
of went on to sort of this day trader,
you know,
dynamic that you saw this kind of the
reverse of that actually kind of started
with individuals and now the
institutional wave is coming on board.
So that's a little bit different,
uh, you know, kind of flavor. Um,
but definitely think the world's
never seen anything like this before.
So it's trying to grapple like what,
what are the metrics,
what is it you compare to visa,
you gold?
Is that the first protocol that can
be monetized? Lots of new questions.
Awesome guys.
Really appreciate it. Stefan's
now going to give, uh,
an awesome presentation about what's in
store on the technical side for ripple.
And then Chris Christmas
going to stay here.
Someone's going to come back and we're
going to do a little Q and a with the
audience,
so take it away.
So what this is trying to illustrate is,
um,
if you deploy into ledger on some network,
and we envisioned that there will probably
be sort of a global instance of it.
Lists like the Internet
has a global instance. Um,
then you have these different nodes,
these,
these little blue notes here
and we call them connectors,
but they're basically like routers in Ip.
So they basically taken
packets on one side.
They look at the destination
on the packet, they compare
it to the routing table,
and then they forward that
packet towards that destination.
Whenever you look at any kind
of blockchain presentation,
there's a pretty good chance you'll see
some kind of graphic that has, you know,
nodes connected by lines. Um,
some kind of graph and, uh,
you know, you'll hear things like
bitcoin is the TCP Ip of money.
And when we hear that,
we cringe a little bit because if you
know anything about how TCP IP works and
how bitcoin works,
there are very different protocols
that do very different things in a very
different way.
Um,
and so the challenge that we always have
when we talk about the interledger is
it is actually a lot like TCP Ip in and
then through this little presentation,
I want to try to convince you as to
why I say that. Um, but, uh, you know,
people already have usually like seeing
some kind of blockchain presentation had
already looks a lot like this, um, but,
but is a little bit more superficial
in terms of the similarities. Um,
and so if I want to send a
packet into this network,
I just send it to whichever connected
I'm connected to and it should find its
way to whatever receiver receiver
I've put on it. So in that way,
it's a lot like two CPIP.
Now you might say, okay,
so you were routing these packets, but
how does actual money really move? Um,
so the way that that works is
that once you have sort of a,
a path and you're sending these packets,
each link is responsible for
its own settlement. Um, so
what we tend to do is, um,
if you have two connectors that have,
um,
a peering relationship with each other,
they're going to have this like pay
packet traffic going back and forth.
And so they're going to look at those
packets and then they're going to
eventually settle. Um, and
for the core of the network,
it makes the most sense to
settle through a digital asset.
And the reason for that is that they
are very easy to move internationally
across borders and you have very low
costs in terms of when you move them.
Um, and since you are going to have a
lot of inbound and outbound traffic,
it's makes sense to stay in that digital
asset, to do all of your settlements. Um,
but of course the majority of,
of people,
users out there don't actually have
easy access to digital assets yet. Um,
and so you do need some kind of a,
some form of support for
traditional payment systems.
And the interesting thing is that all
these settlement networks really do is,
you know, move payments across
or like move money. And so, um,
that's something that is supported
by all the legacy payment networks.
So we will,
we can actually do is we can just
aggregate to a greater degree so we wait a
little bit longer before we settle. Um,
and then we send a one big payment across.
You see that kind of at the
beginning here with the sender,
a down there and the receiver
and upright, um, where those,
those settlements are happening a little
less frequently and there are a little
bit bigger and to probably
a little bit more expensive,
but they can settle lots and lots
of these individual packets. Um,
and so with this architecture,
what that means is that from
an end to end perspective,
we can send a packet at incredibly
low latency. We can send it,
I'm an incredibly low incremental cost.
And so that's really what makes
it feel a lot like the internet.
You can really just connect to lots of
different services and pay for lots of
different things without accumulating
a lot of fees while doing that.
And then sure, it has a settlement
eventually. And you know,
hopefully these a last mile sort of
settlements will get more efficient.
Just like internet connectivity. It
went from you know, 56 k modems, uh,
all the way up to what we have
now where I have a Google fiber.
So very happy with that.
Um,
so yeah,
here's a little chart of like the
actual architecture and again,
if you're familiar with TCP Ip,
you know,
they draw the same kind of picture with
the four layers, um, which is, you know,
sometimes called the
Internet architecture.
It's a little bit less detailed
than the Osi architecture,
but I won't bore you with that.
It's just a reference for the
people that didn't know that. Um,
so the four layers actually work a lot
similar to the very similarly to the four
layers and TCP Ip.
So I just want to go through those four
and kind of give you a sense of how this
all works together.
Um,
the way you should think about the
interledger layer is that's essentially an
abstraction layer.
So that's basically the thing that you
have all the different ways of moving
money below it.
And then you have all the different use
cases for moving money above it and it
kind of brings them all together.
So in the case of the Internet,
it would be the internet layer,
um,
has all the different ways of moving
information below it and all the different
use cases building on top of it.
And so now you can have all
these different combinations.
I can make a Skype call over my
Wifi, I can make a, you know,
send an email over my satellite internet.
So it really doesn't matter what use
case I'm using and which network I'm on,
I can combine them in different ways.
And so this is kind of doing the
same thing, uh, for money. Okay.
Now an application layer,
uh,
this would be sort of the
equivalent of like http SMTP.
This is use case specific.
You would make different application layer
protocols for different use cases. Um,
so one that we've designed so far is
called a SPSP or a simple payments,
separate set up protocol.
Um,
and basically all that does
is it defines what a internet,
it sort of identify it looks like. So
think of that like an email address. Um,
and you could send to that
type of identifier if you
wanted to pay somebody as
on a peer to peer basis or you
could build that into simple apps.
It's not super efficient.
So it's kind of like HDP or it's sort
of the general purpose application layer
protocol. Um, you could make a much
more specialized ones. So for instance,
we did an experiment where we built
payments into web torrent. Um,
so basically to pay the uploaders,
um, but also the content creators, uh,
which I think is really
cool aspect of this.
It's like it's efficient enough that you
can pay a lot of different parties in
the flow of whatever app or interaction
that you're, you're part of.
And we'll see a demo of that in a bit.
But I think this is where I expect a lot
of variety is on the application layer.
Now we're talk about the transport layer.
So if you're familiar with TCPI,
if he does this,
where you find your TCP and TCP is
really common to a lot of different
application layer
protocols that build on it.
And it gives you some sort
of basic services, right?
It gives you a sequencing of packets so
that your data comes out the right order.
Um, it gives you a retransmission
if a packet gets lost,
it'll send it again and so on.
And we have a transport layer
protocol called PSK too.
And it does a lot of the same things.
It's a responsible for doing things
like if you send a large payment,
it'll split it into smaller
chunks and then reassemble them.
It'll do things like retransmission
of payment packets, et cetera. Um,
so again,
like I'm trying to really get across,
like we're copying from the Internet
a lot and we have to um, give, uh,
give them a lot of credit,
cause a lot of the things that they
do actually apply to money very well.
Now the interledger layer is,
um,
is kind of an interesting one because
that's where all the routing happens.
And when we first started out,
I'll tell you one anecdote
about the design of this layer,
which is when we first started out,
we assume that the writing would have
to be quite different because we're
talking about money after all, we're
not talking about information. Um,
and so we,
you know,
we knew about BGP and how it
works and so on what we thought,
a lot of those things
wouldn't be applicable.
We want it to route by
the lowest cost path.
We thought that that was the
most important thing was,
was to minimize the fees.
But as we actually building
it, we realized that, um,
if you optimize by fees,
what can happen is somebody in the
network just advertises a absurd, right?
So they just advertise,
hey,
I can exchange $1 for 600 euros now
that suddenly the best path to take for
absolutely every payment
in the entire network.
Now what do you think is going to happen?
So that note's going to go down,
obviously that right was never real
to begin with. Um, and so you just,
the whole thing just breaks down.
Um,
and so one of the reasons for the way the
BGP is design is to make the length of
the path one of the primary metrics.
And what that does is if someone
advertises some ridiculous metrics,
you still only going to take down his
immediate neighborhood because for
everyone else is still going
to look like a big detour,
a very long path that they
don't want to take. Um,
and so it turns out that even for money,
the length of the path,
it's a very good proxy for all the
other things you might be interested in.
Like how reliable is it, what's
the latency, what's the fees?
Those are all lower or tend
to be lower for shorter paths.
And so we can do exactly what BGP does
in terms of routing by shortest path
first.
And then I'm using other metrics to kind
of tie break if passengers same length,
um, picking the best one. Um, and we
just basically add fee is another metric.
Just like the incident has latency.
Um,
I already kind of talked a
little bit about the settlement.
The key thing to mention here is that
all we need from the settlement layers
that it can transmit money.
It doesn't have to be very fast.
It doesn't have to be very cheap. If it's
slower, we just settled less often. Um,
and just to give you some examples of
the kinds of things we've integrated with
already, um, there's a
extra p patient plugin,
so that's settling using the extra ledger.
Let's see it most efficient
at plugin right now.
That's one of the reasons that
we feel good about the strategy.
It's like we actually seeing in practice
that our own products score really well
on these different metrics.
In terms of like what ledger would you
actually choose for settlement? Um,
we've done a lightening integration,
so we did a little test where we
actually connected the bitcoin lightening
network and the light coin
lightening network together.
If you're not familiar with lighting,
it's basically a scalability overlay
network for, uh, currencies like bitcoin.
And then you could do something like Ach.
You can even do cash if you want, right?
So you can have a relationship with an
intellectual service provider where it
basically says like,
I give you cash up ahead of time,
or you give me cash ahead of time and
then we can exchange packets up to that
amount until we reached that
balance. And then, you know,
we have to settle up again.
Okay. Now with all that, um,
prefix,
I'm going to give you a bit of a live
demo and this is going to go fairly quick.
So pay attention. Um, so, uh,
basically what we're going to show here
is, uh, the easy website maker. Okay.
So easy website maker is an
APP that somebody put together,
just uploaded it to get hub.
And basically it allows you to create a
website from just having a little sketch.
And now obviously we didn't
build all the difficult parts,
the AI parts of what that's what
you guys are for. Um, but, uh,
we did do all the payment stuff,
so all the payments are actually
going through until ledger.
There's actual payment
packets being exchanged.
And we tried to visualize that a little
bit later by having like a log of
packets. Um, and basically
what this APP does,
this I put in a sketch and it,
it goes to one vendor that's offering a,
an API,
a paid API that can turn
sketches into actual html.
And then it'll go pay another vendor
to actually package that into a docker
container and upload it
somewhere. And then, um,
another vendor to host the actual live
website and then another vendor to buy a
domain.
And finally we'll tip the developer.
So I'll go show you what that looks like.
So the first thing you need to
do is I need to pick my sketch.
So I'm just going to grab one here.
And so this is the sketch of my website.
There's probably a
little bit small to see,
but it has like some tax and it has a
little chart and it has some more texts.
And just to be clear, again,
like the AI is mach. Dot.
We didn't actually create the AI just for
the demo. That would be ridiculous. Um,
but uh, yeah, in the future,
this could very well be possible.
So now I'm going to say make my site
and now things are gonna happen very
quickly. So it's going to upload
that sketch to that Ai, sorry. Done.
And now it's uploaded the finished html
to get back to a service that turns into
the docker container.
And as you can see on the right,
and I might do the demo twice as, so
you can see it again, I'm on the right,
you saw the total amount paid.
This is in a XOP drops us would
be 1000000th of an extra p.
So a total paid would be 0.1 XRP um,
which is about,
what does that like 2 cents,
3 cents, sorry, two, $3.
Nobody sends point. What a,
sorry, 2010, that's like, yeah,
it's like 30 cents or
something, whatever. Um,
so you could see like the individual
packets and there's a couple of things
going on. Um, and I think
I will run through the demo
again just so you can see.
So first when we paid that Ai,
um,
we paid a sort of one lump sum amount
and then the packager is actually a
streaming, uh, paid end points.
So that's a paid end point where as we
sended data and we ask it to do things,
we'll stream packets to it to keep it
paid. And if we ever don't keep up,
it'll like stop working
until we pay it more. Um,
and then we deployed it to a host and
bought a domain and then sent a tip to the
developer.
And I can actually click this button
here and I look over here and as you can
see, our website is now up
and I can actually show you,
it's like all of this running locally,
but uh, we got a domain, et cetera. Right?
It's like set it up. Um, so let's go
through a demo one more time just to,
so you can see kind of the, the streaming
payments part a little bit better.
So I'll pick the web, the same
website. So you're on a ride.
You can see like total paid right now
is 500 drops. It's to pay for the AI.
Now we're streaming to
pay for the packager.
So does this going in 258 drop intervals
and then we have a large expense to
host the website. Um, 9,000 drops.
That's over 9,002 to
actually buy the domain.
And then finally we tipped the
developer a thousand drops.
And so if I make an APP like that,
I have a built in business model
and I think that's really the,
the key point to get across here is I
think this will have a huge impact on the
web where think about if I
start a convenience store,
I don't need to think about
what my business model is.
My business model is people pay
me when they come buy things.
When I open a restaurant I don't think
about by business mom business model is
people pay for the food that
they eat on the Internet.
We have this weird thing where like there
isn't a good way to charge people for
using your website.
And so we build advertising,
we build subscriptions and all kinds of
hacky work arounds for like how to get
money out of people just
from visiting your website.
And I think this will present a
pretty efficient alternative, um,
in the future where people can just pay
you for, for the, for using your site.
So that's it. And again,
back to this. Thank you.
Thank you.
Stir fry.
[inaudible]
now we'd like to open it up
to questions from you guys.
Does anybody have any questions? Thanks
for the presentation again. Um, yeah,
so there's like a lot of different
coins that deal with payments,
like a repo light coin, stellar
for example, that I've heard of.
Uh, can you go like a little
bit over what's the different,
like the basic differences between all
those different payment platforms and
then also do you see like one payment
platform just dominating and we all just
use one of them?
Or can these somehow like live in harmony,
kind of like USD and euros and whatnot?
Yeah, maybe I'll do good.
So on the second part, um,
I think it's going to shape out a lot.
Like what you're seeing with a
few currencies. I mean, you know,
the world kind of has four majors, maybe
five majors, and then there's kind of a,
you know, um, everything else. Um,
and I think that probably plays
out here simply because, um,
particularly with this sort of
Wall Street wave that's coming,
a lot of those institutions, they're not
buying how many, 2000 different, you know,
kind of coins and imply
platforms out there.
There's sort of grab and I don't know,
top 10 or five or it's some
smaller number and you know,
in currencies, liquidity begets
liquidity. All of this is about, uh,
how much liquidity, uh,
is kind of, you know,
kind of supporting these
platforms and these and these, uh,
these currencies or commodities,
wherever you want to call them.
There's still a lot of debate
on what they actually are.
So I suspect that's going to accelerate.
And you and,
and that liquidity then it attracts more
use cases. Like for example, ripple.
The company focuses on the
enterprise use case. But you know,
we see these things we see Xrp is, is
very much a general global digital asset.
Without a counterparty. So, uh, you know,
you'll see more and more use cases
popping up from different angles and that
just kind of drives more liquidity.
So I think that's probably the way
it might be, how it pans out. But
yeah, I think the reason we developed
into ledger and the reason we built an
interoperability protocol was
because of that exact realization.
It wasn't going to be
everyone using one system.
There was going to be a
number of different systems.
And actually behind that as another
realization, which is, you know,
my goal has always been, you know,
to solve the problem of, you know,
friction and payments. Right? And so, um,
I realized that the centralization wasn't
necessarily the solution because you
see a paypal,
they come out,
they have free then eventually to
check up their fees when they have an
established market position. But then
you see bitcoin doing the same thing,
not necessarily with us as much slit of
agency, but it still happens that way.
And so what you got to think
about is right now when
you're on a payment network,
you can only send money to the
people on the same network. Um,
and that's kind of like pre Internet
online services where you could have like
compuserve and you can email anyone
on compuserve and you can, you know,
use any services that are uncomfy served,
but you can't access any services
that are on genie. Right?
And so compuserve has this like moat, they
have a defensibility around the reach.
And so that's really what you got to
commoditize what you got to attack.
And so with payments,
it's still that way today where like
if you're on the same payment network,
you can pay each other. If you're on
different networks, you can't. Um,
if you want to pay from your paypal
account to a mobile money account in
Tanzania, you're screwed. You can't, um,
yet I can totally go on my mobile phone
in Tanzania and open any website in the
world, right? So we need that
kind of interoperability.
And that's really what creates a
competition that drives the cost. Um,
the reason we think that Xrp is going to
have a role in this system is because,
um, we've been doing, I mean, not to
toot our own horn too much, but like we,
we've been doing really well in
terms of like the performance and the
characteristics of the protocol.
So I think a lot of people will choose
to use Xrp if there is sort of a lot of
competition was like right now you use
bitcoin even though it's expensive,
you use bitcoin even though it's slow.
Um,
I think if there's a lot of competition,
people will pick the most efficient,
which would be extra p right now.
You know,
that as well.
It's kind of in an environment where a
lot of the volume I think is speculative.
I actually think that kind of use case
has a greater tolerance for costs.
Speed kind of doesn't
really care. Right. Um,
whereas as you started getting into kind
of these use cases where you need like,
you know, millions of some kind of
unit, um, that matters a ton, right?
So as the kind of the ratio of a real
use cases to speculative volume changes,
I think that dynamic becomes
more important. True. I'm
sorry. Next question. Cool.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Uh, Hey, uh, thanks so much for
coming. Uh, my question is around,
so if you're talking about that Xrp
and cryptos are the Internet of money,
the big difference between money and
data is that money's regulated and banks
certainly,
you know,
if they were the like the equivalent
of running the phone lines before,
I have a pretty big incentive to uh,
innovative and sort of get ahead
of a change that that is coming.
So you could see them easily upgrading
the swift protocol to be able to move
money internationally a lot quicker.
And so I'm curious how you
guys see specifically XRP
living in a more regulated
space. I think, you know,
the crypto sort of took the world by
storm and governments are going to
certainly respond the next year or two.
So why do you think that Xrp is going
to be able to live in a much more
regulated industry than data
is? Uh, especially because like,
you could see banks upgrading swift
to be able to support, you know,
maybe like submitted transactions instead
of, uh, transactions that take days.
I want to like quickly question
some of the premises in there. Um,
so I think a lot of the people in the
room I think are very young and so we grew
up after the deregulation of data.
And so like the Internet came out and a
lot of the laws that were around before
then, copyright law, you
know, cryptography laws, uh,
export restrictions around algorithms
and things of that nature, you know,
actually got removed and are safe harbors
got created because the internet kind
of post the technology that was
on the one hand, very useful.
And on the other hand, kind of an
illegal gray area. So I think that um,
the technology,
this if you use it,
it just feels so incredible useful that
it's hard to imagine how regulations
wouldn't be built around it.
Um,
I think that there's
definitely an opportunity for
people to be thoughtful and
intelligent about how to, how they
approach the technology in the meantime.
Like you want to be
compliant, you want to do, uh,
everything that you can to kind of, you
know, stay within the letter of the law.
But there are going to be a ambiguity
is in terms of like just the law is not
written for these kinds of use cases.
So, um, I think that's one thing.
And then as far as like extra Pto,
I think I'll hand it off to Chris.
Yeah, I mean you're raising a, obviously
a key part in has, as I mentioned before,
the Internet of value is
kind of equal parts, uh,
capital technology and compliance
compliance is hugely important.
And the reason is simple.
I think it's just because governments
sorta want to have a monopoly.
I think it's actually a more,
a question of, you know,
data is powerful but money's
more powerful, right? Um,
you know, data can show you,
um, you know, a life saving medicine that
your family might need it, can't buy it.
Money can buy it. On the
flip side, um, you know,
data can encourage a terrorist
to do something awful. Um,
money can buy the weapons, right?
So the stakes are higher. Um,
which I think actually this is going
to have maybe a more profound effect on
earth, good and bad. So regulators have
got to be there every step of the way.
This fantasy that somehow this is
going to bypass governments and bypass
compliance. You know what, that's just,
that's just bs. And you know what?
Nobody wants that.
That is a champagne problem with a bunch
of rich young people that can sit there
behind their computer screens and like
block out a lot of bad things that can
happen. So it just can't go that way. Um,
and so I think we're trying to think about
that. Try to be pragmatic about that.
Cause that's the only way
we're going to have impact.
And if you look at people that are
trying to support what's going on in the
developing world, um, they
are very much wanting to work.
They're not trying to go around,
they're trying to work within the system
because they know that's how you're
going to have impact. Um, so that's,
that's kind of the way we see it.
Your question about swift
by the way. Um, the,
the problem with that point of view
is swift only deals with the data.
They have a correspondent banking partner
that deals with the value and that's
off any sense of an Internet of value.
The whole point here is that, uh,
something like interledger and Xrp
can eliminate the correspondent,
which is actually where all the juices,
right? That's where all the waste is.
That's where the sediment risk is.
That's where the failures are.
That's where the time is.
So swift actually doesn't have the,
the combination of capabilities to do
what you're saying. Right. Cool. Sorry.
So thank you for the question.
Uh,
that's a pretty cool demo and I just want
to learn a little bit of a behind the
scene that, for example, the
Ai, how the full building an AI,
how the money goes to the
Ai Chat Bot. Okay. Um,
so we built a protocol that
kind of takes intellect,
juror on the one side and
takes HDP on the other side.
And essentially you're making rest calls.
So you're making API calls to these back
ends and the first time you make the
call, they all respond with
four oh two payment required,
which is a sort of an error code. An HTP
two was already, we were like, great.
That works for our use case.
And um,
basically it sends you back a header to
tells you all the information that you
need to know to make intelligent
payments to that exact, um,
and point or like the Api server
that runs that end point. Um,
and so that server will be listening for
intellectual packets in addition to the
http requests. Um, and so when
you start paying, um, yeah,
it'll go back into that same receiver
and then the receiver will then a credit
year, what we call like a token. Um,
and then the next time you make a request
that has in the header your token.
And so the receiver will know that you've
actually funded that with some packets
and then you will, you can proceed
through the, through the program. Um,
the streaming version of
the demo to you saw a,
that's a little bit more complicated.
That's probably goes bill beyond,
but we can maybe catch up about it
later. Um, and then, uh, one, uh,
one thing that's also interesting
is that one of the services,
which is the thing that builds a static
site into a docker container actually
itself pays another Api, right? So
you have another API behind that.
And so one of the things that's really
cool is with these streaming payments,
we can actually have sort of
an API that takes in money, um,
in an immediately spends it assets trying
to process that request and then maybe
sends a little bit as profit to the
developer and then returns the results.
So this is a lot of cool
stuff you can do with it.
Great.
Thanks.
Thank you guys for coming to speak today.
I'm kind of curious to learn
more about how you might, uh,
prevent money laundering and, uh,
companies that participate in,
uh, you know, um, uh, you know,
like the payday loan type,
uh, companies from coming on the
system that exploit people financially.
Um, I'm interested to learn more
about that, that sort of thing. Yeah.
So, I mean, I think we, um, we
really try to focus on, you know,
kind of the bottom of the payment stack.
So kind of on the
infrastructure part of it. Um,
and are we going a reason for that is
that a lot of the things that prevent bad
things from happening or kind of top
of the stack and a lot of that actually
doesn't need to be
reinvented. Right? And, uh,
the way we kind of think of it as like,
let's focus on what's really changing.
And we think this is the interoperability.
It's the idea of a digital asset with
no counterparty that can be spending
anywhere in the world that's neutral.
So those are the things I think we can,
we can, uh, can change.
And then piggy back off of this is what
we like kind of the enterprise focus now
is for that as that first
beachhead, um, you know,
piggyback off of what already exists for
hundreds of millions, uh, you know, uh,
people.
Um,
the other thing I would say is that if
this Internet of value becomes a reality,
I think, you know, the prevention
of things like payday lending,
obviously it has to be regulated.
That's a big part of that at every level.
But the other big thing to what
Stefan mentioned before is sort of the
commoditization of reach.
Um, if you have that,
you suddenly now every market
has way more competitors, uh,
for financial products.
And it was something we saw at prosper
and Isla and we got frustrated with
because we were kind of us in one lane.
You couldn't,
you couldn't transport it
to another market because
you were in another network.
Right.
That this future vision I think is
that the world is one big financial
supermarket and you know,
everybody's competing in every market.
I think that goes a long way, but you
still need all the other, you know,
kind of regulatory components. Uh,
pretty much existing at some may go away,
but I'd say probably most of them don't.
I don't know what you want to add to that,
but
yeah, I think like with, with
uh, you know, you mentioned
the anti money laundering,
I think there's sort of a long list
of things that are actually completely
separate issues, right? There's
sort of consumer risk. There is, um,
any money laundering there is, um,
uh, yeah antiterrorism finance,
like there's all kinds
of different things.
So you have to think about when
you're building a, a payment system.
And so if you have a stack like this,
they'll fit in different parts
of the stack. Like for instance,
consumer protection that would
fit in the application layer.
So if you're building an application
where consumers are sending money,
you have to think about,
you know,
how to protect those consumers
from sending it to the
wrong people. If you have,
if you're thinking about
risk or counterparty risk,
that would fit in the sort of the ledger
layer, right? So you have a counterparty,
they settle with you
on a certain schedule.
How do you make sure they
actually settle with you? Um,
so there are a myriad of
things to think about. Um,
I think that it's kind of a losery for
us to come up with all the solutions.
I think we're trying to be thoughtful
in terms of like getting it to a point
where we can start
experimenting with it and,
and kind of get more experienced with it.
Um,
but that's gonna require
sort of a commercialization
of the technology to really
think about, you know, all
of those use cases. Um, and
I would also highlight that,
um, you know, ripple has a
commercial, um, uh, you know,
stack and commercial feature set, and that
is very much like Chris said, you know,
writing within the existing
regulatory framework.
And then we have the open protocols,
which are maybe a little
bit more forward looking.
And I think some of those
questions are more difficult there.
So what you saw us present today
is the more forward looking stuff.
So I think some of those
questions are still open there.
Great. Thank you very much. Thank you. Hi.
Thanks for the presentation.
Um,
so since the tech is currency agnostic,
um,
why,
what would be the incentive to choose XRP
over fear or any other cryptocurrency?
Hmm.
Um,
so this is where it almost love to like
ask my colleague up on stage cause um,
you know,
we have our team who was actually
trying to integrate with these different
digital assets and you know,
different payment systems
and it's just a like a,
like an many orders of magnitude of
difference between extra and let's say
bitcoin.
Um,
and still several orders of magnitude
between extra p in something like light
coin, which is known as a more
efficient, so acid and like, um,
it's just a pleasure to work with.
And part of it is it,
it's been designed for that,
right?
Like it's been designed to be used as the
settlement acid in, into ledger and so,
uh, has a lot of functionality
like payment channels
built in a certain way, um,
that are incredibly efficient for
this particular use case. And so,
um,
I think the big answer,
the main answer is right now
it's just the best thing to use.
Like we talked to people, Hey,
let's, uh, set up a connector. Well,
what do we peer with?
While we could use light coin but what
we could use extra p but x people just to
be cheaper. So let's use XRP.
Um, and so I think as much, uh,
to the extent that like these connectors
are going to be competing with each
other and they're trying to
think about their margins,
experiential is going to look like
a very good option for them. Yeah.
In this world
you'll just, you'll need some
digital asset that is super fast,
super cheap, endlessly scalable, um, that
will serve the world very well, right.
Better than let's say using a
dollar or using a euro, right.
Something that is a
neutral to any network.
So we're absolutely confident
that some digital asset, uh,
will be a key part of
this Internet of value.
But we think that sort of fast co,
you know,
cost and scalability are going to be those
key things and that's what's going to
drive the liquidity that's going
to make these things really useful.
Yeah.
Like extra p is not static either.
It's like we're constantly thinking
about how to help improve it. Um,
there's a community out there. It's
thinking about how to improve it. So, um,
you can expect that it will get better as
well as, as, um, you know, time goes on.
Final question. Hi. So I was still, uh,
in the very beginning of your presentation
about how you think except piece
better over bitcoin in a sense
that bitcoin is a lot slower,
a lot more expensive, but um,
but is there for a reason, right?
Cause it requires like at least six
confirmation across the network in Warren
Person's action to happen and,
and that is their invoice would
address the double spending problem.
So I was just curious,
like in your own words,
how does that Xrp addressed it that
will spend problem if it's just a
confirmation between the
two notes. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so if you're not technical please, you
know, do something else for a little bit.
Um, cause there's no way to answer that
question without getting into some of the
technologies. So, um, bitcoin
users or consensus process,
which is essentially based around the
assumption that a majority of hashing
power will never be held by a, you know,
a coordinated, malicious attacker. Um,
and so if you're watching what the
majority of hashing power is doing,
you'll tend to be on a state of the
network that is reasonable and it doesn't
contain, you know, reverse the
transactions and so on. Um,
however the protocol as such does
allow rollbacks, right? So you can,
if somebody else presents you
with a chain that's longer,
it has more hashing power behind it,
you will roll back your
transactions and switched to that.
And I know that because I was one of the
first person people to implement a full
node bitcoin re implementation
from scratch. Um,
so I wrote that code and it's very
complex and knowing code to write.
So I will remember that forever. Um, on
the ripple side, such code does not exist.
There's no way to roll back network.
Now how is that possible? Well,
the way that ripple works is,
um, as I mentioned before,
the user select these validators.
Um,
and then we essentially
use that input as a, um,
as an input to sort of an algorithm
where we look at the graph of what people
selected and then we run a consensus
on validators that are central to that
graph or like that are highly
trusted within that graph.
And so it's sort of this two step process.
And what that means is that when the
first step is complete and you'd try,
you've identified which
validators you're looking for, um,
you don't have to worry about there being
like more hashing power just over the
horizon.
Like once you hear from the validators
that you've identified it as being the
ones that are validating or like the
ones that you, you're listening to, um,
then you don't have to worry about
some other validate are coming in later
saying like, no, actually we decided
this. You just didn't hear about it yet.
And so there's no need to roll back or
to, um, to rewrite history. One smell.
It does have committed to a decision.
They can't change their minds essentially.
Um, and so that has a couple of, um,
impacts where like a couple of ways that
the protocol is different because of
that. Number one, you only have
to wait for one confirmation.
You wouldn't wait for
multiple confirmations because
values can change their
mind. You can't roll back. So there's
no probabilistic aspect to it. Um,
number two is, uh, we can, um,
process or we can create blocks on the
cadence so we can create blocks and like
a, a fixed interval as opposed to a random
interval like bitcoin where, you know,
blocks can come out very close together.
They could,
there could be no block for a long time
because we know which validators they're
supposed to generate blocks
they can generate them on
that cadence. Um, and then,
uh,
finally
I think that'll cover everything.
Yeah,
yeah. Whatever it is, there's
a really good talk on, um,
why shouldn't call it real good,
but there's a talk by myself
on consensus.
Um,
but you can find out from the consensus
thousand 17 conference where I go into a
little bit more detail and I'm also
happy to talk to you afterwards,
but that's kind of the high
level quick description.
Cool
guys,
thank you so much for coming.
Uh,
do you have any final statements or do
you want to tell people how they can get
involved in the rebel community at all?
Yeah, so for interledger
there's intellectual.org, um,
which at the time of recording
this horribly out of date,
but hopefully by next week
should be showing you all
the latest, greatest stuff.
Um, there's a community group at
the w three c called Di intellect,
your community group that's open
to anyone to just register. Uh,
we have a mailing list where we discuss,
you know,
how these protocols work together. Um,
all the code for the demos and everything.
Um, you can find that on github.com/intel
Ledger and slash into ledger js.
Um, and then for ripple ripple.com if
you're a bank, you know, let us know.
Reach out if your payment provider and
we've maybe if worked for Google payments
or anything like that, let
us know. And then, um, for,
there's another project which we didn't
really mention today. Um, but that's also,
uh, was also using the demo in the
background, which is called Codea.
So that's basically the hosting a
system that's paid within to ledger,
and we uploaded the website to it.
Um,
there's a lot of cool use cases around
hosting if you're thinking about
serverless hosting, et cetera. So if you
enter that, there's codis.org as well.
C O d I s.org. Awesome. Chris,
Stefan, thank you so much for coming.
Really appreciate it.
[inaudible].